ten years ago this month Airbnb ten
years ago Airbnb has been in business
think about that disrupted the hotel
industry and changed how people travel
its latest innovation is selling what
you do on vacation as much as where you
sleep there are more than 15,000
different experiences they're calling
them around the world that you can book
on the site now and they include
everything from walking with wolves to
aerial yoga Jamie yuccas shows us how
these experiences are often
picture-perfect adventures tailor-made
for social media
[Music]
Arizona pilot Craig Judd is giving me
the ride of a lifetime in his 1943 open
cockpit biplane or as the air BnB
platform calls it an experience
Judd is one of almost 15,000 people
around the world sharing their skill
hobby or passion with paying customers
who find them listed on Airbnb three out
of four millenials young people said
they'd rather buy an experience than a
physical good and so I think the
experience economy is this huge wave
Airbnb CEO Brian Chesky launched the
experiences feature on his platform two
years ago he says it's now growing 10
times faster than the company's core
home rental business we want the
experience to be so good that you do
them even if you lived in the city
I live in the same city as burlesque
performer Catlett Co II but I never
would have imagined doing this it makes
you happy be like a one-stop shop for a
traveler because they're gonna stay
somewhere and then they're gonna see
what well can I do
Oh or in my case what else can I try to
do with some of these experiences you're
taking a great risk how do you kind of
vet these people will have a very
specific protocol to make sure it's safe
make sure people have the licenses the
regulations to be able to do this this
is Lea Terri Lockwood already had years
of experience as a master falconer
before she and antonella's and Polly
started offering this experience I
talked to so many people that loved
falconry and I wanted them to get a
taste of it shoulder towards bird oh wow
to compete with anybody you must be
different and you must be better air
B&Bs competition for the experiences
market includes
you see hotel chains like Marriott which
launched its moments program last spring
for every dollar that a customer spends
on the hotel and the airfare they spend
three dollars in the city and so it's an
attempt to capture some of that fortune
senior editor Li Gallagher says Airbnb
is banking part of its future on a
market still in its infancy
you know experiences isn't something
that everyone needs you need a hotel
room you need a place to stay
you don't need an experience so they
have to in some ways manufacture the
demand and that's not easy to do but
neither is learning how to maneuver a
world war ii era by plane and air B&B z'
philosophy is why not give it a try
there you go we don't travel the sleep
in a house or in a hotel we travel to
have experiences for CBS this morning
Jeanne you guessed high / Mesa Arizona
and they've got some really cool stuff
for The Walking with wolves a photoshoot
at the Eiffel Tower because they said
listen material things you can come and
go but you can always hold onto the
expiry and then number that yeah I like
that
there's something there for everybody